le constat ce matin c'est que la
pauvreté s'aggrave en France le dernier
rapport annuel du Secours Catholique
nous apprend ceci la moitié des
bénéficiaires vite avec moins de 5 euros
par jour et par personne phénomène qui
s'aggrave de 3 points en 2 ans 5 € pour
s'habiller pour manger pour sortir aussi
et parfois c'est encore moins
[Applaudissements]
je finis juste une chose parce que un
moment donné les gens se sont des coups
de couteau et du ridescentes qui a lieu
il y a quelques semaines et encore
aujourd'hui mais quand il va y avoir la
pénurie dans les porte-monnaies de
thunes à qui vont mettre des coups de
couteau
sur des schémas de violence parce que ça
devient catastrophique en Sonia a payé
son loyer et ses factures il lui reste
chaque semaine 10 € pour pouvoir manger
avec vos enfants
il faut surtout se dire il faut pas
qu'il t'arrive un couac mais je vais
prendre d'abord pour mes enfants je
n'enlève pas de la bouche de mes enfants
mais moi je vais me priver chaque
centime compte pour Sonia tes alarmes
antivol sur du fromage de la viande du
chocolat dans des boîtiers verrouillés
et des étiquettes magnétiques sur du
beurre dans certains supermarchés
britanniques ces produits alimentaires
courants sont protégés comme des
produits de luxe on les met sous antivol
car beaucoup de gens partent avec ces
produits sans payer venez voir à Londres
ou aux USA si les jeunes ont la flemme
il bosse et ont des mentalités de winner
pas des loosers comme dans ce vieux pays
mais il y a énormément de raison mais on
n'a pas eu le temps de développer plus
mais aussi les questions nationales il y
a aussi la question de l'éducation
nationale mais il faut tout changer
en 2020 500 pieds de vie ont disparu
dans l'Hérault
dans le Gard un champ entier d'asperges
avant même leur récolte en passant par
220 poules pondeuses en Bourgogne
certains ont même arraché du chanvre en
Gironde pensant qu'il s'agissait de
cannabis
des personnes qui remplissent leur sac
de nourriture et quittent les magasins
en courant des scènes quotidiennes au
Royaume-Uni
près de Birmingham Paul Chima gère deux
supérettes le bacon les saucisses et
tous les fromages ça c'est le rayon
sensible c'est ça qu'il vise le mariage
se coupe américain en connaît un rayon
Jessica et Mike se sont dit oui dans le
lieu de leurs rêves leur supermarché
préféré une union possible après un
concours organisé par la marque discoint
tout était aux couleurs de l'enseigne du
sol jusqu'au pomme ces photos diffusées
à fond la caisse sur les réseaux sociaux
laisseront à coup sûr au jeu de mariés
un souvenir impérissable en tout cas ce
qui en ont ils sont très attachés 17% à
vous qu'ils pensent d'abord aux cadeaux
pour leur animal avant de penser au
cadeau pour le reste de la famille voilà
c'est le cadeau prioritaire il y a une
mouche qui s'invite sur le plateau
Jean-Luc Reichmann l'écrase ça vous rend
fou oui non mais c'est parce que c'est
la mise en service c'est la mise à mort
d'un animal peu importe quel qu'il soit
et donc c'est on n'est pas dans l'arène
ici j'ai envie de dire donc j'ai pas
envie que des individus s'amusent à
rigolent sur le fait un animateur soit
perturbé par un animal et qu'il
s'arrange le droit de le tuer mais au
bout de quelques secondes le journaliste
s'est fait voler la vedette par un jeune
pachyderme à la trompe baladeuse
difficile de garder son sérieux dans ses
conditions déjà plus de 10 millions de
vues en deux jours et les fantastes
parce que vous faites régulièrement
partie des personnalités préférées des
Français et ça j'imagine que ça vous
touche Anne ah oui ça me touche je suis
jamais dans les premières mais je me
maintiens
et vous maintenez moi il y en a qui
sortent du classement
[Rires]
donnez-moi votre place pour une année
voilà c'est pareil et puis en fait
surtout c'est au niveau des températures
qu'il fera le plus froid demain
après-midi à Aurillac avec 8°c
vraiment merci c'était passionnant de
vous écouter
je ne sais pas pourquoi
Marine il veut pas que ça passe à
l'antenne
si on peut
[Musique]
on peut continuer parce que si vous
voulez